let's kick this off yes right yeah get
me out of this conversation with Brandon
how about this from Miguel Rojo
Brendan looks like a go-kart mechanic
[Laughter]
one piece that one's easy oh yeah that
little hi girls
Theo looks like he drives swamp boats
for over Brendon probably lives in a
gated community this is on gay you open
the gate
looks like he sells glow sticks that
Juggalo festivals do you wanna [ __ ] and
enjoy the experience are you gonna see
your weed this will make me laugh so
hard
Brandon was like the type that will end
up in area 52 during the 51 recall chin
man with everybody Theo von looks like
he was drawn up by Mike judge we do look
like beavers a Butthead Brandon looks
like a buff pigeon I'm talking about bro
dude pigeon bro that's the DJ that's uh
this the fillet of Detroit bro got that
broke the cycle dude those last two are
there certain hitters Theo was the kind
of guy that sneakers pay raccoon into a
yellow of concert
the phones do man he likes him too you
know it's like he sells bananas at a
Grateful Dead concert aciem selects one
Brennan is the final boss you have to
beat at a cologne kiosk in the mall King
Koopa baby King Koopa that Buckingham
although that estee lauder Bowser bro
you that Christian Dior dragon Baba's
battles are Johnny Depp